this might be the closest palestinians
of god to holding elections
in 15 years a presidential decree
setting three dates
for legislative and presidential
elections and those for the palestine
liberation organization or plo
the announcement marks a breakthrough in
a palestinian divide
that lasted more than 13 years
factions will meet in cairo within a
week and resolve some important
technical issues
to ensure fair and transparent elections
we are aware that there are problems but
we are certain that they'll be resolved
and if not we can resolve them
previous agreements to hold elections
didn't materialize
because attempts at reconciliation
between the two most dominant
palestinian parties fateh and hamas
failed this time they say they will hold
elections first
and then discuss how to end their
divisions
the last time palestinians cast their
ballots in general elections
was in 2006. the unexpected hamas
victory triggered the divide in 2007
and paralyzed the legislative council
hamas became the de facto ruler of the
besieged gaza strip
and fatah remained in charge of the
occupied west bank
father's leader mahmoud abbas was
elected in 2005
and has remained in office ever since
there's a concern that fatah and hamas
will agree on a unified list
this would take the meaning out of these
elections and minimise participation of
independent
civil society and the youth may serawi
works in the palestinian election
committee
at 32 years old she's never had the
chance to vote
i'm optimistic we need new faces to
serve we've been waiting for this
opportunity for a long time
a majority of palestinians want general
elections that will fight corruption
and restore unity but recent polls show
that they
don't believe that's possible more than
half of palestinians say that even if
they're held
they won't be free or fair
al-jazeera the occupied west bank